on va faire une table ou première fois
parfait plus personne ne bouge pas j'ai
repris le pouvoir
premier choc l'opéra premier premier
première résultats d'examens à l'opéra
contre les filles j'ai essayé de se
jeter sous les voitures se taper la tête
contre les murs premier mensonge
souvenirs je déteste le mensonge jouer
le rôle d'une menteuse menteuse elle non
allemands être cinq ans de sa vie à sa
vie mais vous vous souvenez intégristes
de la vérité bien premier péché je crois
pas aux clichés
vous croyez pas empêché non karine silla
me croyez pas qu'on paie cher ailleurs
le fils tué oui oui c'est tout à part ça
n'y a pas de pêcher moi je sais pas donc
ça va elle n'est pas catholique comme
vous c'est peut-être pour ça que j'ai
été élevé là dedans nous a bossé
premièrement une dizaine d'années
viennent quand j'avais une dizaine
d'années alors la veste et sylvain
oubliée non premier baiser une cour
d'école sombre me donnait une réception
à bon vous excuser déception alors après
ça va mieux
premier flirt poussé à une belle
histoire à ce moment vous
enfin une belle histoire maintenant rien
genre poussée qui va pousser jeu quand
tu mets un peu la main tu sais quoi
pousser pour toi jean chez le boucher
c'est vrai c'est bien de faire une
petite billie premier vrai amour
oui le premier flirt poussé correspond
au premier vrai amour est pas mal ah oui
ça va mieux la première rupture c'est
avec lui aussi deux jours après non non
pas de jour quand même attendu fait de
la peine à combien non quelques jours
après après aussi revenir on a souffert
voilà on se repousse voilà et la
première cuite sa date de cette époque
oui oui je devais avoir une quinzaine
d'années oui je veux faire la maligne
une bonne bouteille de vodka ça me
faisait rien puis je suis tombé premier
pétard m'avait tout
non non je fume pendant trois pétards
non essayer peter berg regardes tu peux
aller chercher une bière donc fermé les
menus fermer les volets mais là non
cette époque premier succès j'ai pas
dire institutrice de me faire pousser
non d'ampoulés dire ça tu as tu sais
c'est la première fois qu'on m'a fait
confiance et votre édition
si votre premier rôle le capa oui